what a lovely movie what a lovely movie
it was pretty good so I just saw Mad Max
fury road and whoa holy hell I'm still
processing everything this film had so
much time surrounding it even when
Rotten Tomatoes giving it a 98% then I'm
glad I'm reviewing this film the
following day because at first I wasn't
sure how to feel about it I watched the
first two Mad Max films I never got
around to the third one but watching
this modern-day take on it was so
kinetic so fast paced it was so
different that I wasn't entirely sure
how to respond but after thinking about
it yeah this film it's pretty [ __ ]
sweet what everyone's saying about this
film is that it's an amazing action film
some are saying that it's one of the
best of years some are saying it's one
of the best of all time some are even
saying it is the best of all time some
are even saying God doesn't exist but
this movie exists essentially this film
was I got 90 minutes a two-hour car
chase but it's done like Mad Max style
meaning you get the awesome production
design to get the incredibly assembled
vehicles you get insane Road thrashing
so serious like brutal deaths sometimes
watching death in a movie is so cool
it's never cool in real life but
sometimes you know like watching people
get killed you're sick you're you're all
sick but the movie was greedy it was
haunting it was violent yeah it's like
not grotesque that's actually something
I greatly admire about this film it like
feels more disturbing and violent than
it actually is showing you there's
really not much core in this film when
there is gore it's like so fast-paced
that you don't even remember what it
looked like I loved it because this
whole plot this whole story takes place
in the middle of this adventure like the
trailers don't give away the plot for
you so I don't want to ruin it for you
either like a short synopsis for me
Charley's Theron is on the road to
somewhere where people are trying to
stop her and she gets the help of Mad
Max and hence the chase ensues it's
interesting because this movie is mainly
but it does take time for character in
like little moments you learned about
the characters like throughout the
adventure through how they're responding
to this adventure without having like
expositional dialogue you see when I
first walked out of this film I was like
that dude did it have much character but
that's I thought about it more I
realized that it just didn't have like
expositional dialogue George Miller not
Frank Miller you say Frank Miller a lot
of people are gonna kill you trust me
but George Miller has this like
wonderful ability to like come up with a
story and it's like post-apocalyptic
world driven by the power of fuel and
water resources rather than making his
films like a big exploration of this
world he always focuses on the plot and
he only allows his characters to say
what they would say in that moment of
time so it actually wouldn't make sense
for these like strangers coming together
during this really high intense chase
sequence to start giving a bunch of
expositional dialogue but if you pay
attention to story and the characters
all they're like this film has a pretty
strong theme about redemption they're
about three main characters in this and
it's really targeted towards redemption
and it's interesting because you
actually understand more of the
characters and how they respond to the
violence how they go about the violent
moments and in between George Miller
really allows his actors to provide that
depth without having to tell the
audience exactly everything about
someone's past or what they're currently
thinking Tom Hardy as Mad Max Mel Gibson
played the original max and that was a
legendary character and I'm so glad that
Tom Hardy wasn't trying to be Mel
Gibson's max Tom Hardy's backs actually
seems like you might be older he seems
very haunted by the wasteland on to by
his mistakes from the past he's like
actually going a little insane at times
she sort of reminds me from that weird
creepy boy from the road warrior because
Tom Hardy's Max is sort of like an
aggressive boy like he doesn't speak
much she doesn't there's a lot of
grunting a lot of that like you could
tell he's a really violent threat but
you can still so see that he has a heart
but similar to how I sort of perceived a
road warrior
Max is sort of used more as a character
device to support the bigger picture of
other characters like Charlize Theron
character the trailers didn't reveal who
she really was so I'm not going to
she's fantastic in this film she's
someone who's also haunted by the demons
of her past and some present-day
mistakes too she's a warrior a protector
just like that Charlize Theron would be
to me in real life if my girlfriend
shaved her head like Charlize Theron we
would have serious relationship issues
that would not be okay with that she
only has one hand the other is
mechanical if I have a mechanical hand
you know what I use that for I don't
know where these jokes are coming from
but she kicked some serious ass in this
film this film actually has a lot of
badass females you got young badass
females middle-aged badass females and
even elderly badass females it's like
the fine brothers show except with
kicking ass instead of reacting with
Charlize Theron I really bought her as
his character you know to see Charlize
Theron on-screen I were usually like
it's Charlize Theron she's really
beautiful and yeah she's a great actress
but I'm still aware as you saw at least
there and I really liked how she went
all out with this she was not the most
attractive in this film but her ability
to like transform into this badass
one-handed lady was [ __ ] dope but the
true scene stealer for me was Nicholas
Hoult like I keep saying I'm not gonna
give much away they don't say whose
characters in the trailer but Nicholas
Hoult performance man that's the one
you're gonna walk away thinking about
like a plum introduction he seems like
oh okay he's just another crazy Mad Max
villain with each scene he gets they
give him more and more to do and you
explored him actually more than you
would even explore max of this film the
film was great too for doubt the
character's name don't know the actor's
name but I like the villains motives in
this film it was different from the
other villains that's that's actually
what I like about this whole franchise
the first Mad Max the gangsters are like
serial killers on wheels the road
warrior had villains that were like
tribal territorial savages in a way this
one is more like a cult it's like a
civilization ruled by evil religious
thinking so I like how the characters
are always like [ __ ] crazy but they
always have a different type of thing
about them the music of this film is
wonderful it really does get your heart
going
I love the editing of this film I love
like the man
craziness the kinetic energy that just
the camera angles and the editing bring
to the film I'll be honest I strongly do
prefer the first half over the last half
that's not to say the last half is bad
it's just the last half had like one or
two small moments that seemed to drag a
little bit and the actions started
seeming a little repetitive but then
again there's just so much [ __ ] action
that I don't even know actually if it
was repetitive it might have been
different it's just so much in your face
that you know it's like what was that
different than what I saw so yeah if you
don't walk away thinking about the
characters necessarily you will not
forget the action in this film it's so
cool because it's from the same writer
director of the original Mad Max but he
like really updated it like he's been
paying attention to films over the last
30 years and I feel like in a lot of
ways this has some of the best moments
of the entire franchise because those
action scenes are like cleverly
choreographed at what school is that yes
there's some CGI here and there but it's
mainly practical effects and like crazy
stuntmen and at the end of the day it
has just enough character to provide the
emotional depth to support the action
scenes let me get straight to the point
here all in all I gotta say Mad Max fury
road got it manically right
alright guys checking out my interview
for Mad Max fury road you can go ahead
and follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
last but not least you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos is out doing to clear this button
up my dick to subscribe that's right the
dick let me tell you something about
this little road warrior he goes by the
name max and every time max gets mad his
girlfriend
gives him a furious road head huh
see what I did I put a head after the
word road